hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
interesting features of Epicurus is
moral philosophy and moral psychology as
well is that when it uses the term
pleasure he doesn't mean just one thing
he actually distinguishes and the whole
epicurean tradition will distinguish
between two different kinds or two
different types of pleasure
fundamentally different from each other
on this basis some of them are what they
call moving or kinetic pleasures and
some of them are what are called static
pleasures and you notice that I've put
static pleasures in between moving
pleasures and pains now why did I do
that well this is where Epicurus is
going to differ from other hedonists
from the ancient world so you know the
other hedonist had held and I think this
is a very natural view that many people
have that you've got pain on the one
side and you've got pleasure and then
you know what's in between neither
pleasure nor pain a kind of neutral
state Epicurus will actually argue that
the the the neutral state is not a
neutral state that it's in fact the best
the most pleasurable state it's exactly
what you want to try to get to or if we
want to be more exact you want that
state with a little bit of this stuff
you know just not enough to actually get
you stuck in pains and this is
something that is really central to
Epicurus position you can't understand
his position adequately or do moral
reasoning based on that position without
taking this this distinction into
account and the implications of it
there's a few things that he says that I
want to highlight from the principal
doctrines and the letter to Matt I see
us so one of the things that he says in
the principal doctrines he says if the
objects which are productive of
pleasures too prolific eight persons
prolific eight persons are people who
are just you know pursuing pleasure all
the time that that lacks self-control
when it comes to Plato's I make dumb
imprudent decisions you know there are
the kinds of people who do what we call
impulse buying you know they're the ones
that all these kiosks are set up for at
gas stations and you know rest stops and
supermarkets you know because they can
count on them to buy buying as a matter
of acquiring things that we think are
going to give us pleasure or we're going
to ward off pain so he says if the
objects which are productive of
pleasures too prolific at persons which
are primarily kinetic pleasures really
freed them from fears of the mind the
fears I mean inspired by celestial and
atmospheric phenomena the fear of death
the fear of pain it further if they
taught them to limit their desires we'd
never have any fault with that then they
would be filled the pleasures to
overflowing on all sides and would be
exempt from all pain whether a body or
mind that is from all evil for epicures
pain is what is bad right so you want to
have a life that's free from pain does
that mean that instead you ought to like
go to the other extreme and try to pile
up as much pleasure as possible no as
we're going to see when we look at his
theory of practical reasoning in another
video oftentimes many of the pleasures
that he's calling kinetic pleasures will
themselves bring pain take drinking for
example right drinking is fun that's why
people like to drink you know there's
all sorts of reasons that we could go
into it probably could do a whole video
about that but oftentimes with drinking
comes being hungover saying and doing
things you know if you go out to the bar
cost good money or if you're drinking
you know very expensive champagnes or
wines or liquors that's you know you're
going to feel some pain when your
locator your bank account the next day
all right so these these pleasures that
are generated by doing something or by
you know consuming something by taking
something in by some sort of change
they're caused by some sort of change
that's why they're called kinetic
pleasures they are not the sum total of
pleasure in part because as he says they
can't actually take away the pains the
really big pains that tend to make our
lives uh you know less than than happy
lives less full lives so the things that
he's talking about are you know fear of
death you know a lot of people try to
deal with their fear of death by a
hedonistic lifestyle not an epicurean
hedonistic lifestyle but some other kind
of hedonistic lifestyle and that only
works for so long you know or they try
to deal with you know the loss of a
relationship the loss of a job like you
know going out and having a good time it
doesn't really take away the concerns
that one has it could be worries about
money it could be worries about
relationships it could be worries about
all sorts of things this the the
condition of static pleasure of being
free of pain being free of worry a state
of rest or so to you know being
satisfied being untroubled being unpaved
literally by pains fears worries that at
the Cure says is actually much more
pleasurable for us than the types of
pleasures that we we get through doing
something consuming something he he goes
on and he says in the letter to men
osseous that we have no need of pleasure
the pleasure of this sense or we have
been a pleasure sort of this sense when
we when we are pained when we grieve is
how the translation does literally when
we feel pain of some
that pain could be fears or troubles it
could be an actual physical pain because
pleasure is at present when we do not
agree when we've removed that when we're
in the state of static static pleasure
we don't really need this kind of
pleasure over here because we're already
feeling good if we want to add some of
this that's the gravy that's the meat
right that's that's what we really want
that's just an addendum to it so he says
on this account we affirm that pleasure
is the beginning and end of living
happily right so a lot of times when
we're feeling pains of some sort we want
to use pleasure in this sense as a kind
of compensation to distract us to take
our minds off of things Epicurus would
say no you really need to address the
reasons why the cause is why you are
feeling these worries these pains you
have to address that so you can get here
because if your goal is simply to try to
mask it or to you know overcome it for a
short time you swing from this extreme
over here but this is going to take you
right back there again because many of
those kinetic pleasures are themselves
going to bring later on other pains so
that's a key idea as well he goes on and
he says when we say the pleasures
achieve good we're not talking of the
pleasures of the debauch man or those
which lie in sensual enjoyment as some
think our ignorance and don't entertain
our opinions or interpret them
perversely to be an epicurean does not
mean stuffing your face full of stuff
doesn't even mean stuffing your face
full of the finest you know foods and
wines while beautiful music is playing
because those are all moving or kinetic
pleasures to be an epicurean means first
of all trying to live a life that is
this free from worry and from pain as
possible you limit these kinds of
pleasures so that they don't bring about
pain so that you can actually enjoy this
and then Yuri incorporate some of those
pleasures so he says we mean the freedom
of the body from
the soul from confusion it's not
continued drinking and reveling or
intercourse with boys and women or
feasts of fish and other such things
fish was a kind of a delicacy as a
costly table supplies that make life
Pleasant but so this shows us what the
static pleasures consistent sober
contemplation which examines into the
reasons for alteration avoidance and
which puts to flight the vein opinions
from which the greater part of the
confusion the pain arises which troubles
the soul so for Epicurus this is really
what our focus ought to be upon that's
the kind of hedonism that he is putting
up interestingly this is something about
which other people as he says you know
those who misinterpret our doctrines a
lot of people would say look those
Epicureans they're just about maximizing
this kind of pleasure over here they
would ignore the distinction or they
would say look I don't understand how
you can mean pleasure in two different
ways this is what the epicurean doctrine
was and still is for those who have you
know take it as a guide today